pas de stylo pas de radio pas de
journaux pas de discussions politiques
les visites ont lieu une fois par mois
mon problème à rester en vie a lentement
club stade je pourrais facilement m'y
habituer vous êtes le mandela blanc
celui qui se bercent le plus dilution
quoi qu'il arrive dans ce tribunal
on a entendu parler de vous deux vous
avez pris combien huit ans pour moi
eidos pour lui mais on n'a pas
l'intention de rester si longtemps ce
mur fait six mètres de haut il ya des
barbelés tout autour de la cour des
gardes armés jusqu'aux dents de notre
retour en cellule jusqu'à l'aube des
tunnels
quelle que soit la direction et vous
ramènerai tous jusqu'à la prison tout le
monde arrive ici en s'imaginant pouvoir
se faire la belle la semaine suivante ou
ya un début à tout c'est exactement mon
avis si tu crois que tu vas pouvoir
fabriquer au clae amelia crayon il ya
bien sûr faire en bois
c'est complètement dingue donc tout ce
qu'on a à faire c'est fabriqué une clé
est extrêmement complexe qui fait en
sorte qu'elle atteigne la serrure situé
de l'autre côté de la porte de l'arrêt
de 8 cm d'épaisseur alors qu'on n'y a
absolument aucun accès
j'adore cette idée en cas d'échec
vous prendrez 25 ans si vous avez de la
chance ou une balle dans la tête si vous
en avez pas arrêter tout
c'est quoi cette chose timberlake toi tu
te penches comtois
[Musique]
votre plan tout entier voué à l'échec je
n'abandonnerai jamais
il n'a rien fait pour mériter ça
on est des prisonniers d'opinion c'est
pas la même chose pour nous nous on est
des prisonniers de guerre
rotules c'est quoi m'attendre
c'est nous priver nous c'est avec ça
qu'on va lutter
soit disant moi
accrochez vous à cette colère elle vous
rappelle qu'il existe un autre monde
en dehors d'ici
[Musique]